Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Interior Chinatown is an all-new series based on the best-selling novel by Charles Yu about a struggling Asian actor who gets a bigger part than he expected when he witnesses a crime in Chinatown. Streaming November 19th only on Disney Plus. The epic return of Yellowstone is now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus. You destroy me, you destroy yourself. Unlike you, I keep my promises. The wait is over. Yellowstone, new episodes now streaming exclusively on Paramount+.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。《唐人街内幕》是一部全新系列剧，改编自查尔斯·于的畅销小说，讲述了一位苦苦挣扎的亚裔演员在唐人街目睹了一起犯罪后，得到了比预期更大的戏份。11月19日开播，独家上线 Disney Plus。《黄石》史诗级回归，现正于 Paramount Plus 独家热播。你毁灭了我，你也毁灭了你自己。与你不同，我一言九鼎。漫长的等待已经结束。《黄石》全新剧集现正于 Paramount Plus 独家热播。
The faster money and data move, the further your business can go to a seamless digital future for Canadians. Let's go faster forward together. In Life, Interact. For the first time, Nelson realized what he was up against. This was nothing like the American War, for the French Revolution had unleashed something much darker and more terrifying.
资金和数据流动得越快，您的业务就能越快迈向面向加拿大人的无缝数字未来。让我们一起携手，加速前行。Life, Interact。纳尔逊第一次意识到他所面对的是什么。这和美国独立战争完全不同，因为法国大革命释放出了更黑暗、更恐怖的东西。
The unbridled fury of a fanatical mob, the savage passion of a people bent on slaughter. Suddenly he thought of home, of his father and Fanny and the little church at Burnenthorpe, and the gentle fields and sleepy villages of England. And at that moment, he knew he could not rest until these monsters were beaten. But high above Toulon's smoking ruins, a man in a blood-stained uniform gazed coldly across the harbor and on the face of Napoleon Bonaparte was a thin, cruel smile of satisfaction. So that was a wholly unbiased perspective on the siege of Toulon in 1793, written by a top historian of the French Revolution, Dominic, namely yourself. And this is from your new book for children, instilling in
那是狂热暴徒无法无天的怒火，是一群一心想要屠杀的人们的野蛮激情。突然间，他想到了家，想到了他的父亲、范妮、邦内尔索普的小教堂，以及英格兰温柔的田野和宁静的村庄。就在那一刻，他知道，除非这些怪物被击败，否则他绝不罢休。然而，在土伦冒烟的废墟高处，一个穿着血渍斑斑制服的男子冷冷地凝视着港湾，在拿破仑·波拿巴的脸上，浮现出一丝薄而残酷的满意微笑。以上就是对1793年土伦围城战完全公正客观的视角，由法国大革命顶级历史学家多米尼克，也就是你本人撰写。而这出自你的儿童新书，旨在向
them a new sense of patriotism and suspicion of French revolutionary fervour. And what's called Nelson, God of the Seas? Nelson, Hero of the Seas. Nelson, Hero of the Seas. The latest volume, Tom, in the best-selling Adventures in Time series. And I think people will say, scrupulously fair and forensically researched. So what I will say is that we've done, how many episodes have we done now of the French Revolution? 13, I think. And it's good that you're absolutely letting everyone know what
他们灌输一种全新的爱国主义精神，以及对法国大革命狂热的怀疑。这本书叫什么来着？《海洋之神纳尔逊》？《海洋英雄纳尔逊》。《海洋英雄纳尔逊》。汤姆，这是畅销书《时空历险记》系列的最新一册。我想人们会说，这本书极其公正且经过了严密的考证。所以我要说的是，我们已经做了，我们现在究竟做了多少集法国大革命的节目了？我想有13集吧。你毫无保留地让每个人都知道
your perspective on the French Revolution is, in case anyone had been in any doubt. It's not necessarily my perspective, Tom. it's Horatio Nelson's perspective. That's what it is. That's what it is you see. This is what a great literary artist does, he takes you into the minds of his characters. So today Nelson is going to war and we left him at the end of our first episode, Francis declared war on Britain, this means that the Royal Navy must be summoned to serve both as sword and shield. And Nelson has been given a ship, hasn't he? The Agamemnon. Yes. So let's remind ourselves, Tom, where we got to. The French have declared war on
你对法国大革命的看法，这很好，免得任何人产生怀疑。汤姆，这不一定是我的看法。这是霍雷肖·纳尔逊的看法。事实就是这样。你看，这就是伟大的文学艺术家的做法，他把你带入了他笔下人物的内心世界。所以今天纳尔逊要参战了，我们在第一集结束时讲到，法国对英国宣战，这意味着皇家海军必须被召集起来，既当利剑，又做盾牌。纳尔逊已经分派到了一艘船，对吧？“阿伽门农”号。是的。那么汤姆，让我们回顾一下，我们进度到哪儿了。法国已经对
Britain. We're at the beginning of 1793. And Captain Nelson, who is 34 years old, this slender, sickly man, but a man who is fired by a really extraordinary sense of self-belief, kind of Churchillian actually, the kind of self-belief that in a lesser person would be the act of a lunatic. But Nelson can talk the talk, he can walk the walk as people say. A God given mission. Exactly. So in February 1793, we find him at Chatham Dockyard, probably your favourite dockyard. It is my favourite dockyard.
英国宣战。我们正处于1793年初。34岁的纳尔逊舰长，这个身材苗条、体弱多病的人，却是一个被一种真正非凡的自信心所点燃的人，甚至有点丘吉尔式的风格——这种自信心放在一个平庸的人身上，简直就是疯子的行为。但纳尔逊不仅说得到，而且正如人们所说，他也做得到。上帝赋予的使命。完全正确。所以在1793年2月，我们在查塔姆造船厂找到了他，这大概是你最喜欢的造船厂。它确实是我最喜欢的造船厂。
Preparing his new ship for sea and this is the Agamemnon. We talked in the last episode that Nelson is the embodiment of something bigger and so is the Agamemnon. It was 12 years old, it was built of English oak, 200 feet long, 50 feet wide. I mean this is a very, very expensive and high class piece of kit, isn't it? Exactly, hardware. And his job, I know you love victuals and supplies. I do because it's so important. We touched on this in the previous episode, but just to reiterate, a ship cannot spend long times at sea unless
他正在为出海准备他的新船，这就是“阿伽门农”号。我们在上一集里谈到过，纳尔逊是某种更宏大事物化身，“阿伽门农”号也是如此。它当时有12年的舰龄，由英国橡木建造，长200英尺，宽50英尺。我的意思是，这是一件非常、非常昂贵且高档的装备，对吧？没错，是硬核装备。而他的工作——我知道你热爱军需给养。我确实很喜欢，因为这太重要了。我们在上一集里简单提到过，但在此重申，一艘船如果
it is very well supplied. So Nelson makes sure that the Agamemnon, you know, there's biscuit and there's flour and water and beer and wine. And I mean, they actually bring on bullocks, live bullocks at times. But also you have to keep people supplied with fruit. So this is where the American term for the English limeys comes from because Royal Navy vessels are loaded down with limes and oranges and lemons and all kinds of things to keep scurvy at bay. And Nelson understands this as well as anybody in the Navy and his men are always incredibly healthy. And this is something that, you know, you have a lot of initiative as captain. So it's
给养不足，就无法在海上长期逗留。所以纳尔逊确保“阿伽门农”号上有饼干、面粉、水、啤酒和葡萄酒。我的意思是，他们有时甚至还会带上阉牛，活的阉牛。但你还得保证人们能吃上水果。这就是英国人被称为“莱米”（limeys）的美国称呼的由来，因为皇家海军的舰船上装满了酸橙、橘子、柠檬和各种各样的东西，用来防止坏血病。纳尔逊对这一点的理解不亚于海军中的任何人，他的船员们总是极其健康。而且，你知道，作为船长，你拥有很大的自主权，所以
not just that you take what is given to you. You have to order a lot of this stuff yourself. So he has ordered the wine, the port, the sherry, he's ordered the tea and Turkish coffee, a keg of tongues, which sounds a little bit intimidating. But also, this would appeal to you, Tom, since you're always interested in the religious dimension to history. Nelson goes out of his way to order hundreds of prayer books and hymn books for his crew from the Society for the Promotion of Christian Knowledge, because he is, of course, a vicar's son, and he believes that, you know, regular services, which some captains are not really into keeping up. Nelson is very keen to keep them up because he is of course a vicar's son and he believes that you know regular services which some captains are not brilliant at keeping up. Nelson is very keen to keep
不只是接受别人给你的东西。你必须自己订购很多这类东西。所以他订购了葡萄酒、波特酒、雪利酒、茶和土耳其咖啡，还订购了一小桶牛舌，这听起来有点吓人。不过，这会很合你的胃口，汤姆，既然你一直对历史的宗教维度感兴趣。纳尔逊特地为他的船员从基督教知识促进会订购了数百本祈祷书和赞美诗，因为他当然是一位牧师的儿子，他相信，你知道，定期的礼拜——有些船长并不大热衷于保持这一点。纳尔逊非常热衷于保持这一点，因为他当然是一位牧师的儿子，他相信，你知道，定期的礼拜——有些船长并不擅长保持这一点。纳尔逊非常热衷于保持
them up because he thinks it's really important. Well I suppose it builds a sense of community doesn't it? Absolutely it does. And it reassures everybody on board that God is an Englishman which is very important when fighting the French. Yeah which is as we will see from this story. It's absolutely true. It certainly appears to me. So to get his crew, again, for an officer, for a captain,
这一点，因为他认为这真的很重要。我想这建立了一种社区感，对吧？当然是的。这让船上的每个人都确信上帝是个英国人，这在与法国人作战时非常重要。对，正如我们从这个故事中将要看到的。这绝对是真的。在我看来确实如此。所以为了招募船员，同样地，对于一个军官、一个船长来说，
the onus is really on you to find a lot of your crew. So he puts up posters and hands out pamphlets in Norfolk. He gets a lot of people from Norfolk. For his lieutenants, he gets old friends from his days in the Caribbean. As his midshipmen, as the kind of apprentice officers, he gets the sons of well-to-do Norfolk families. So people that he might owe a favour to or people that are friends of his father or something like that. One of these is his stepson, Josiah, who is 13. Yes. Good and bad news for Josiah. The good news is he is big, he's strong, he's manly, he's very enthusiastic. The bad news is that by common consent Josiah is absolutely useless and a complete and utter
寻找大量船员的重任实际上落在了你身上。因此他在诺福克张贴海报并分发传单。他从诺福克招募了很多人。至于他的副官，他找的是他在加勒比海时期老朋友。至于他的见习官，也就是类似学徒军官的人，他找的是诺福克殷实人家的子孙。也就是说，他可能欠过人情的人，或者是他父亲的朋友之类的人。其中之一是他的继子若西亚，今年13岁。是的。对若西亚来说，这是个好坏参半的消息。好消息是，他身材高大、强壮、有男子气概，而且非常热情。坏消息是，根据大家的共识，若西亚绝对是个废物，完全是
waste of space. Well, although he will feature heroically at the end of this episode. He will do. So that's why it's important to bring him in now. So bear that in mind. Of course, there are press gangs that go out. There are press gangs. But by and large, Nelson has a good reputation and so people want to serve with him because
在浪费空间。不过，他在本集结束时会有英雄般的表现。他会的。所以现在把他引出来很重要。请记住这一点。当然，也有强征水兵的帮派在行动。确实有强征水兵的帮派。但总的来说，纳尔逊享有良好的声誉，所以人们愿意和他一起服役，因为
they know that he will do right by them, that there's a good chance of winning prize money. So this is crucial part of what you want. Anyone who's read Patrick O'Brien's novels will be familiar with the fact that Royal Navy captains are always looking for the chance to make a bit of extra money by capturing enemy ships. And generally there's a feeling that Nelson is someone you want to serve with. He will look out for you. He will do right by you. And that's incredibly important. It is very important. And the thing about doing right, we don't know many details of a lot of the crew.
他们知道他会公正对待他们，而且有很大机会赢得奖金。所以这是你想要的至关重要的一部分。任何读过帕特里克·奥布莱恩小说的人都会熟悉这样一个事实：皇家海军船长总是希望有机会通过捕获敌舰来赚点外快。而且大家普遍认为纳尔逊是一个你想和他一起服役的人。他会照顾你。他会公正对待你。这极其重要。这非常重要。说到公正对待，我们并不了解许多船员的详细信息。
We just know the names and the muster roles. But we do know, I think this is a lovely detail, that he took 20 ships boys from London's Marine Society, which was a charity that basically gave poor and destitute boys a second chance at sea. So they're all from broken homes or they're from troubled backgrounds. Of these 20 boys, we know that only six of them could read and write. They are undoubtedly malnourished, small for their age, and they're given by the charity a little sea outfit with a comb and a needle and thread and some clothes.
我们只知道他们的名字和名册。但我们确实知道——我认为这是一个可爱的细节——他从伦敦海事协会招募了20名航海男孩。这是一个慈善机构，基本上是给贫困和赤贫的男孩提供在海上重获新生的机会。所以他们都来自破碎的家庭，或者有著麻烦的背景。在这20个男孩中，我们知道只有6人识字。他们无疑营养不良，身材瘦小，慈善机构发给他们一套小水手服，里面有梳子、针线和一些衣服。
And all the rest of the details of their lives are kind of lost to us. So we have to imagine these 20 boys on the ship with the prayer books, with the keg of tongues and all the limes and whatnot. And they're probably better fed, healthier and better looked after than thousands of boys would have been back home in Britain. Yeah. Well, so to quote just on the topic of health again, because it is so important and N.A.M. Rogers, a great historian of the Navy, he said that sailors in the Royal Navy must have been the healthiest body of British subjects in the world. And since Nelson is particularly attentive to this, probably, you know, the sailors on the Agamemnon are even healthier than the vast
而他们生活中的其余细节对我们来说基本上都失落了。所以我们必须想象这20个男孩和祈祷书、一桶牛舌以及所有的酸橙等东西一起在船上。他们可能比英国老家的成千上万个男孩吃得更好、更健康、照顾得更周到。是的。嗯，所以仅就健康这个话题再引述一下，因为这太重要了。海军伟大历史学家纳姆·罗杰斯曾说，皇家海军的水兵一定世界上最健康的英国国民群体。由于纳尔逊特别关注这一点，所以“阿伽门农”号上的水兵可能
mass of sailors. And you were talking about boys, we don't know much about them, but they're, of course, the midshipmen, these little boys, you know, 13 years old when they first sign up. We have a record from one of them when he set sail with the Agamemnon and he wrote to his father and said, Nelson is acknowledged to be one of the first captains in the service and is universally beloved by his men and officers. Oh, that's nice. So that's good to know, isn't it? Yes, that's very good to know. So they set off, they join Admiral Hood's squadron off the coast of Cornwall. That's about 50 ships of them. And of those 50 ships, 18 of them
比广大普通水兵还要健康。你刚才谈到男孩们，我们对他们了解不多，但当然还有见习官，这些小男孩，（他们）刚入伍时才13岁。我们有其中一个人的记录，当他随“阿伽门农”号起航时，他写信给父亲说：“纳尔逊被公认为是海军中顶尖的船长之一，深受其部下和军官的爱戴。”哦，真不错。所以这很高兴得知，对吧？是的，这真的很好知道。于是他们出发了，在康沃尔海岸附近加入了胡德海军上将的舰队。那里大约有50艘船。在这50艘船中，有18艘
are what are called ships of the line. That means they are fighting ships. The rest of them are frigates and kind of support ships and things. And this is a taste of Britain's naval might because actually at that point in 1793, there are more than 600 ships of various kinds in the Royal Navy. There are 14,000 guns, there are 100,000 men. So this is a mighty, mighty enterprise. Britain does not like fighting wars on land. Britain's strategy is always, we will basically give subsidies to whoever it might be, the Austrians, the Prussians, to do the fighting for us.
被称为列阵战舰。这意味着它们是主力战舰。其余的是护卫舰、各类支援舰等等。这是对英国海军实力的一次领略，因为实际上在1793年那个时候，皇家海军拥有600多艘各种类型的舰船。有14,000门大炮，10万名士兵。所以这是一项极其庞大的事业。英国不喜欢在陆地上打仗。英国的策略历来是：我们将基本上向无论什么人——奥地利人、普鲁士人提供补贴，让他们替我们去打仗。
Which is what they've done in the Seven Years war, haven't they? To great effect. To great effect in the seven years war. And this is what we are hoping to do again. And I think the strategy at this point, so for William Pitt, for the other British politicians, they are thinking, you know, maybe this will be another three, four, five year war, we'll get the Austrians and the Prussians to take care of the French on land, we'll do the business by sea, and then hopefully it'll be done and dusted in this revolutionary nonsense will be put to bed.
就像他们在七年战争中所做的那样，对吧？取得了巨大成效。在七年战争中取得了巨大成效。而这正是我们希望再次做到的。我认为当时的战略是，对于小威廉·皮特和其他英国政客来说，他们在想，也许这将是又一场三、四年、五年的战争，我们将让奥地利人和普鲁士人在陆地上对付法国人，我们在海上处理业务，然后希望一切尘埃落定，这种革命的胡闹就会被平息。
Because unlike Goethe, they haven't been at the Battle of Valmy and seen a new age of humanity beginning. So they fully appreciate what they're up against. I think that's absolutely right. If you'd said to them, you're going to be at this for what? The next best part of 20 years, 22 years? I mean, they would not have believed you. Anyway, Admiral Hood has been given the Mediterranean squadron and the task of this
因为与歌德不同，他们没有经历过瓦尔米战役，也没有看到人类新时代的开始。所以他们完全没有意识到自己面对的是什么。我认为这绝对正确。如果你对他们说，你们将为此坚持多久？接下来的将近20年、22年？我的意思是，他们是不会相信你的。无论如何，胡德海军上将已被委任指挥地中海舰队，这个舰队的
squadron is to go down into the Med to aid the Austrians in Italy and to strengthen the bonds with other smaller European powers who might be useful allies. So a good example is the Kingdom of Naples, which of course will play a very prominent role in Nelson's life. So off they go, and by the summer of 1793, they have reached Toulon, which is the major French naval base on the south coast of France. I mean, basically, just to emphasise, I mean, essentially, Toulon is France's Mediterranean sea power. Yes.
任务是深入地中海，援助在意大利的奥地利人，并加强与可能成为有用盟友的其他较小欧洲强国的联系。一个很好的例子就是那不勒斯王国，它当然将在纳尔逊的生活中发挥非常突出的作用。于是他们出发了，到1793年夏天，他们到达了土伦，这是法国南部海岸的主要法国海军基地。我的意思是，基本上，为了强调这一点，土伦本质上就是法国在地中海的海上力量。是的。
Without Toulon, France cannot operate in the Mediterranean. Absolutely right. So Toulon, as people may remember who listen to our series about young Napoleon, Toulon is a city in turmoil. There has been a royalist uprising in Toulon and when Hood arrives, he sends a message to the royalists and he says, listen, if you hand over your dockyards, your ships and your forts to the Royal Navy, I will protect you and I will guarantee you against the revolutionary, the Jacobin armies. And amazingly, they say, okay, that sounds like a good deal. And at a stroke, Hood has won control, or so it seems, of France's preeminent Southern
没有了土伦，法国就无法在地中海行动。完全正确。所以土伦，正如听过我们关于年轻拿破仑系列的听众可能记得的那样，土伦是一座处于动荡中的城市。土伦发生了一场保王党起义，当胡德到达时，他向保王党发送了一条消息，他说：“听着，如果你把造船厂、舰船和堡垒交由皇家海军，我将保护你们，我保证你们免受革命的、雅各宾军队的侵害。”令人难以置信的是，他们说，好吧，这听起来像是个好交易。一举之间，胡德赢得了——或者说似乎赢得了——法国卓越的南部
naval base. However, getting too long is one thing, but keeping it is a bit more tricky. Too long is kind of stuck between the mountains and the sea. It can't really supply itself. So they need supplies. And as you were saying before, nobody is better at kind of getting limes, rustling up a few lemons, a few bullocks. They're Nelson.
海军基地的控制权。然而，占领土伦是一回事，守住它则更加棘手。土伦有点卡在群山和大海之间。它实际上无法自给自足。所以他们需要补给。正如你刚才所说，没有人比纳尔逊更擅长弄到酸橙、凑齐几个柠檬和几头阉牛了。
And so Admiral Hood says to Nelson, look, can you go over please to Naples? King Ferdinand there is pretty sympathetic to us. Well, I mean, very sympathetic. Yeah. Firstly, because he's a king. Yes. And you know, he as a king, he knows what happens to kings with French revolutionaries. In particular, his wife, his queen, Maria Carolina is the sister of Marie Antoinette. So she really knows what she's up against. She hates the revolution with an absolute burning, white-hot passion. Well, understandably. I mean, Ferdinand's a terrible man.
因此，胡德海军上将对纳尔逊说：“听着，你能去一趟那不勒斯吗？那里的斐迪南国王对我们挺同情的。”嗯，我的意思是，非常同情。是的。首先，因为他是个国王。是的。而且你知道，作为国王，他知道法国革命者会怎么对待国王。特别是他的妻子、王后玛丽亚·卡洛琳娜是玛丽·安托瓦内特的姐姐。所以她非常清楚自己面临的是什么。她对革命怀有一种绝对炽热的、白热化的仇恨。嗯，可以理解。我的意思是，斐迪南是个可怕的人。
There's nothing he enjoys more. I mean, he'd be up there with Franz Ferdinand and the Kaiser. I mean, he loves shooting animals of every description. I think that's a very harsh comparison. No, no, no. Well, okay. He's worse, isn't he, really? He's far worse. He'll piss in a chamber pot and then throw it at his servants. He will.
他最喜欢的事情莫过于……我的意思是，他简直可以和弗朗茨·斐迪南大公以及德皇相提并论。我的意思是，他热爱射杀各种动物。我认为这是一个非常严厉的对比。不，不，不。好吧，好吧。他更糟糕，不是吗，真的？他糟得多。他会在便盆里尿尿，然后把它扔向他的仆人。他真的会这样。
There's a notorious occasion where he made his coachman swallow a live frog. He's a terrible man. Franz Ferdinand never did that. I want to go on the record. No, he did not. We'll put that on the record. I couldn't believe it when you brought Franz Ferdinand into this because Ferdinand IV is a shocking man. Anyway, Nelson arrives outside Naples. Now, of course, to somebody like Nelson, even though he's well-travelled, Naples must have been an extraordinary sight.
有一个臭名昭著的场合，他让他的车夫生吞了一只活青蛙。他是个可怕的人。弗朗茨·斐迪南从来没做过那种事。我想记录在案。不，他没有。我们会把它记录在案的。当我听到你把弗朗茨·斐迪南牵扯进来时，我简直不敢相信，因为四世斐迪南是个令人震惊的家伙。无论如何，纳尔逊抵达那不勒斯郊外。现在，当然，对于像纳尔逊这样的人来说，尽管他见多识广，但那不勒斯一定是一个非凡的景象。
So beneath Vesuvius, smouldering over the bay, and Naples is one of the biggest cities in Europe at this point. Third after London and Paris. It is a confusing, chaotic jumble of palaces and churches. It's a city of contrasts, I think. Yeah, where's the Neapolitan tourist board? chaotic jumble of palaces and churches. It's a city of contrasts, I think. Yeah. Where's the Neapolitan tourist board? It's a place seething with excitement and tension and drama, a very
所以，在海湾上方阴云密布的维苏威火山脚下，那不勒斯是当时欧洲最大的城市之一。仅次于伦敦和巴黎，位居第三。这是一个令人困惑、混乱交织的宫殿和教堂的杂烩。我认为这是一座充满对比的城市。是的，那不勒斯旅游局在哪里？宫殿和教堂的混乱交织。我认为这是一座充满对比的城市。是的。那不勒斯旅游局在哪里？这是一个充满兴奋、紧张和戏剧性的地方，非常
melodramatic kind of place. When he gets there, he meets, well, he meets one person who's not very melodramatic and another person who is. The person who isn't is the British envoy to Naples, Sir William Hamilton. He featured in the second season of Love Island. Yes, of historical Love Island. Britain's most famous cook hold, but that's preempting the story. I'm not a massive fan of Sir William Hamilton.
具有情节剧色彩的地方。当他到达那里时，他遇到了——嗯，他遇到了一个人，不怎么具有情节剧色彩，而另一个人则非常戏剧化。那个不戏剧化的人是英国驻那不勒斯特使威廉·汉密尔顿爵士。他在《求爱岛》第二季中亮相过。是的，历史版的《求爱岛》。英国最著名的古董收藏家，但这有点剧透了。我不是威廉·汉密尔顿爵士的超级粉丝。
I think he's a bit of a drip actually. He's not a drip. I think he's a drip. He's not a drip. I think he's a drip. Tremendous contribution to classical scholarship. So that's wonderful. Exactly.
我觉得他其实有点无趣。他才不无趣。我觉得他挺无趣的。他才不无趣。我觉得他挺无趣的。他对古典学术做出了巨大的贡献。所以这很棒。没错。
You arrive and he's just going to talk to you about the Etruscans. Well, unless you're Mozart, in which case he would host you. Yeah, he would, but I'm not. I'm not interested in volcanoes and he's passionately interested in volcanoes. But also you love a monkey, don't you? He kept a pet monkey. Yeah, but I mean, I'd expect that from everybody in Naples. And he has tremendous tastes in women.
你一到那儿，他就会跟你大谈伊特鲁里亚人。嗯，除非你是莫扎特，那样的话他会接待你。对，他会，但我不是。我对火山不感兴趣，而他对火山有着极大的热情。而且，你也喜欢猴子，对吧？他养了一只宠物猴。对，但我的意思是，我会期望那不勒斯的每个人都这样。而且他对女性有着非凡的品味。
Well, Emma Hamilton is his much younger wife. I'm not a massive fan of Emma Hamilton, as you will know, Tom. There we disagree. She is a lady with a colorful past. You've put down here, strump you will know, Tom. There we disagree. She is a lady with a colourful past. You've put down here, strumpet. Well, okay. I mean, she was. Yeah. Yeah. Am I wrong? Tell me I'm wrong. No, but you know, a girl's got to do what she's got to do. And again, we mentioned Gerter. Gerter's a big fan of her. She does these kinds of classical poses. She's very brave. She's very loyal. She's very warm hearted. And I think above all, she is fun. She's also narcissistic, cruel, attention seeking and incredibly annoying.
艾玛·汉密尔顿是他年轻得多的妻子。正如你所知，汤姆，我不是艾玛·汉密尔顿的超级粉丝。这一点我们意见不一。她是一个有着丰富过去的女士。你在这里写的是，荡妇——你知道的，汤姆。我们意见不一。她是一个有着丰富过去的女士。你在这里写的是：荡妇。好吧，好吧。我的意思是，她确实是。是啊。我错了吗？告诉我我错了吗？不，但你知道，女孩总得做她必须做的事。而且我们再次提到了歌德，歌德是她的超级粉丝。她摆出这种古典的姿势。她非常勇敢。她非常忠诚。她非常热心肠。而且我认为最重要的是，她很有趣。她也很自恋、残酷、爱出风头而且极其讨厌。
Well, you can't be everything. We're going to do a future episode on this. Let's not get bogged down. This is clearly going to be the point at which the rest of this history falls apart. They'd really take to Nelson. They think Nelson is brilliant and they promote his interests with the King and Queen. They say, come on, make sure you give him everything he needs. So off he goes back to Toulon. When he gets back to Toulon, he discovers, oh no, terrible scenes. A fella called Bone Apart, Corsican artillery officer has got all these guns
嗯，人无完人。我们以后会做一集关于这个的节目。我们别在这里纠缠不清了。这显然会成为《一切皆历史》分崩离析的节点。他们真的很喜欢纳尔逊。他们认为纳尔逊太棒了，并在国王和王后面前为他美言。他们说，快来，确保给他提供他需要的一切。于是他回到了土伦。当他回到土伦时，他发现，哦不，可怕的景象。一个叫波拿巴家伙，科西嘉炮兵军官，把所有这些大炮
like up to the heights, he's bombarding the forts. The defences of Toulon are cracking. Nelson's not there to see the fall of the city. Hood sends him off to patrol the coast of Italy, but he's in Livorno. Leghorn. Leghorn, as the British call it, where the first boatloads of refugees arrive and he is shocked by their condition. He writes to Fanny, he says, fathers are here without families, families without fathers, terrible scenes. They've had to evacuate Toulon. The French have seized it. And of course the French, they sack the city.
运上了高地，他正在轰炸堡垒。土伦的防御正在崩溃。纳尔逊不在那里见证这座城市的陷落。胡德派他去巡逻意大利海岸，但他在利沃诺。里霍恩。英国人这样称呼它，第一批难民船在那里抵达，他被他们的状况震惊了。他写信给范妮，他说，这里的父亲没有家庭，家庭没有父亲，可怕的景象。他们不得不撤离土伦。法国人已经占领了它。当然，法国人洗劫了这座城市。
Well, because it's full of counter revolutionaries. And this is the kind of the peak of the terror. So actually, I thought this might be a chance to think about those two characters, because Nelson and Napoleon are often thought of in opposition to each other, aren't they? Well, you know, the Abel Gantz film, the famous black and white film. And there's a sequence where Napoleon is fleeing Corsica with his family and a Royal Navy ship. An officer sees it through his telescope and says, should we fire? And his captain says, no, let's not let them be. You know, they won't do any harm. Nelson. It's Nelson. And Nelson had wanted to finish off Napoleon.
嗯，因为那里到处都是反革命分子。这是恐怖统治的顶峰。所以实际上，我觉得这可能是一个思考这两个人物的机会，因为纳尔逊和拿破仑经常被视为彼此的对立面，不是吗？嗯，你知道，阿贝尔·冈斯的那部著名黑白电影。有一个场景是拿破仑和他的家人乘坐一艘皇家海军船只逃离科西嘉岛。一名军官通过望远镜看到了它，并说：“我们要开火吗？”他的船长说：“不，别管他们。你知道，他们不会造成什么伤害。”纳尔逊。这就是纳尔逊。纳尔逊曾想结果拿破仑。
So even in France, I guess, there's a kind of recognition that Nelson is perhaps Napoleon's only worthy adversary. Well, Napoleon later on, when he moved into the Tuileries Palace, he genuinely had a little bust of Nelson. Yeah, his great rival. And I think one of the interesting things about them, they are both enormous egotists. So we were talking about Nelson's great sense of his own star quality. I mean, the only person who really rivals that in the politics of the
所以即使在法国，我想，人们也有一种认识，即纳尔逊也许是拿破仑唯一势均力敌的对手。嗯，拿破仑后来搬进杜伊勒里宫时，他真的有一个纳尔逊的小半身像。是的，他的死敌。我认为关于他们的一件有趣的事情是，他们都是极端的自大狂。所以我们一直在谈论纳尔逊对自己明星气质的强烈感知。我的意思是，在18世纪末的政坛中，唯一真正能与此媲美的人就是拿破仑，他也认为自己是一颗明星，并被这种巨大而专横的野心所驱动。实际上，我认为他们之间的一大区别在于，纳尔逊受到其体制忠诚的约束。所以他在一个能够引导这种野心的体制之内。但我也认为从性格上讲，我的意思是，他对政治权力不感兴趣。不，你说得对。他是个保守派，小写的保守派。他想维持和维护这些框架。
late 18th century is Napoleon, who also believes himself to be a star and is driven by this gigantic overweening ambition. And actually, I think one of the big differences between them is that Nelson is constrained by his institutional fealty. So he's within an institution that channels it. But I think also by temperament, I mean, he's not interested in political power. No, you're right. He's a conservative, small C conservative. He wants to maintain and uphold the frameworks.
我的意思是，他真的是个伯克主义者。是的，他确实是。而且我也认为他不是一个好战分子。他喜欢指挥的刺激。他认识到他会从战争中获得个人利益。但在整个这段时期里，他确实认为英国应该以公平的条件缔结和平，当然。他并不像拿破仑那样致力于战争，话虽如此，两者之间确实有相似之处，因为纳尔逊在海上想要做的事情——
I mean, he's a Burkean really. Yeah, he is. And also I think he's not a warmonger. He enjoys the excitement of command. He recognizes that he will profit personally from war. But throughout this period, he does think that Britain should be making peace, you know, on fair terms, of course. He's not committed to war, I think, in the way that Napoleon is, but having said that, there is a parallel because what Nelson wants to do at sea, in
换句话说，赢得彻底的胜利，歼灭敌人。这就是拿破仑在陆地上旨在做的事情。正如这将使拿破仑能够在欧洲确立法国的统治地位一样。纳尔逊也明白，他所追求的那种胜利对于英国生存和维持其对海洋的控制是必不可少的。完全同意。但从短期来看，既然土伦已经失守，他们实际上在地中海需要一个新的基地。碰巧的是，理想的地方正是拿破仑的故乡，拿破仑的出生地——科西嘉岛。所以胡德海军上将说：“好，我们要去攻打科西嘉岛，因为那是完美的基地。它在法国和意大利之间。我们去攻打它。”所以在1794年春天，他们的目标首先是东海岸的巴斯蒂亚。他们在轰炸城市墙壁。纳尔逊身处战斗的中心。有那么一刻，他差点被杀。
other words, win a complete victory, annihilate the enemy. That is what Napoleon is aiming to do on land. And just as that is what is going to enable Napoleon to establish French rule over Europe. So also Nelson understands that the kind of victories that he's after are essential if Britain is to survive and maintain its command of the seas. Agreed. But in the short term, they actually need a new base in the Mediterranean now that too long has gone. And as it happens, the ideal place is Napoleon's homeland, is Napoleon's birthplace of Corsica. So Admiral Hood says, right, we'll go for Corsica because that's the perfect base. It's between France
敌人的一个火枪弹击中了紧挨着他的一块巨石。巨大的碎片到处飞溅，它们从他身旁飞过，差一点击中他。如果击中了的话，很有可能就没以后了。嗯，我的意思是，他当然会在适当的时候被击中。是的。这也提醒我们，尽管有那些惊险刺激的一面，但这是一项非常严肃的事业。你知道，一次失误，一次失足，就像在第一次世界大战的战壕里把头探出胸墙一样，这就可能意味着一切都结束了。我的意思是，这就是海战的本质。还要指出的是，纳尔逊总是穿着全套制服，因为他觉得军官有责任本质上吸引注意力，这样他的部下就知道他在哪里。是的。他身先士卒。他不是那种军官。事实上，当他有机会
and Italy. Let's go for that. So in the spring of 1794, they target Bastia, first of all, on the eastern coast. They're bombarding the city walls. Nelson's in the thick of the action. There is a moment when he is almost killed. So an enemy musket ball smashes into a boulder right next to him. Huge splinters fly everywhere and they fly right past him, almost hit him. And had they hit him, there is a good chance that could have been that. Well, I mean, he will of course be hit in due course. Yeah. And it's a reminder actually of how for all the sort of swashbuckling side of
被告知“哦，你为什么不留在后面从那里指挥我们？”时，他总是说：“不，我必须在前线。”嗯，在一场海战中，英国军官被期望站起来。其他所有人都可以，你知道，当子弹呼啸时蹲下来。军官必须站起来。我的意思是，这需要疯狂的勇气。当然，从长远来看，这对纳尔逊来说将是致命的，但这是非常长远的未来。随后巴斯蒂亚陷落，他们继续前往科西嘉岛西海岸的卡尔维。这是岛上最后的法国堡垒，这将是一个很难啃的硬骨头。它背靠群山。卡尔维有100门大炮。纳尔逊知道这将是困难的。
it, this is a really serious business. You know, one miss chance, one miss step, just like putting your head above the parapets in the trenches in the first world war or something. And that can be it over. I mean, that's the nature of naval warfare. And also just to point out that Nelson is always in his full uniform because he feels it's the responsibility of an officer to essentially attract attention so that his men know where he is. Yes. He leads from the front. He is not an officer. In fact, when he's given opportunities
他当时确实写信给范妮：“勇敢的人只死一次，懦夫一生死多次。我们无法逃避死亡。如果它发生了，请记住，这是掌握生死之权的那位主宰的意愿。”这很“纳尔逊”。他并不是完全宿命论，但他对危险有着清醒的认识。或者你可以说他有一种感觉，上帝与他同在，他的生命掌握在上帝的手中。所以这是慢工出细活，纳尔逊再次身先士卒进行轰炸，那是7月12日清晨，敌人的炮台开火了，纳尔逊正和他的军官们说话，一颗法军炮弹猛烈地砸进他们堆在周围的沙袋里。实际上发生的是，它将大量石块和弹片碎片直接喷射到纳尔逊的脸上。
to, oh, why don't you stay at the back and direct us from there? He always says, no, I have to be at the front. Well, in a sea battle, it is expected that British officers will stand up. Everyone else can kind of, you know, crouch down as the bullets whistle. An officer has to stand up. I mean, it requires insane levels of bravery. And of course, in the long run, it will be fatal for Nelson, but in the very long run. So then Bastia falls, they move on to Calvi on the western coast of Corsica. This is the last French fortress on the island, and it's going to be a really tough nut to crack. It's backed by mountains. They have a hundred guns at Calvi. And Nelson knows it will be difficult.
你知道吗，多米尼克，我见过那个地方。是吗？我去过那个地方，那里有一块用法语写的理石牌匾，上面布满了弹孔。真的吗？我想那是科西嘉人对纳尔逊的蔑视。但后来我当然意识到科西嘉岛的每一面都布满了弹孔。这没什么针对性。
He actually writes at this point to Fanny, a brave man dies but once a coward all his life long. We cannot escape death. Should it happen, recollect that it is the will of him in whose hands are the issues of life and death. That's very Nelson. He's kind of not exactly fatalistic, but he's realistic about the dangers. Or you could say he has a feeling that God has. God is with him, that his life is in God's hands. So it's slow work, Nelson again leading from the front and bombardment and it's early on the morning of the 12th of July when the enemy batteries open up and Nelson is talking to his officers and a French shot slam into the sandbags they've got heaped around them. And actually what happens is it sends up a huge spray of stones and shrapnel right into Nelson's face.
最妙的是，这完全反驳了西奥在聊天里写的话。西奥在这次录音的全程中一直感到恼火和愤怒，他写道：“法国根本没有人知道纳尔逊是谁。真的，甚至没人听说过他。”嗯，我想科西嘉人会说科西嘉其实不是法国。我想他们会这么说。也许他们没听说过他，因为标志上到处都是弹孔。谁知道呢？是的，也许吧。无论如何，他倒下了。他痛苦不堪，双手捂住眼睛，随即被送到医生、外科医生那里。从这一刻起，他的右眼就再也
Do you know, Dominic, I've seen the very spot. Have you? I've been to the very spot and there is a marble plaque written in French and it's absolutely peppered with bullet holes. Really? And I thought that's the Corsicans showing their contempt for Nelson. But then of course I realized that every side of Corsica is peppered with bullet holes. It's nothing personal.
什么也看不见了。他的右眼被沙子和所有这些杂物击中，就这样，它彻底废了。所以多米尼克，说实话，我觉得这前半部分我们已经经历了足够多的戏剧性事件，所以在这个扣人心弦的时刻我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看纳尔逊是从眼部伤势中恢复过来，还是就此退役，再也没有人听到他的消息。
The lovely thing about that is it completely contradicts what Theo has written in the chat. It's Theo who's been chafing and fuming during the whole of this recording has written, no one in France knows who Nelson is. Genuinely, nobody has even heard of him. Well, I suppose the Corsicans would say that Corsica isn't really France. I suppose they would. Maybe they haven't heard of him because the signs are all peppered with bullet holes. Who knows? Yeah, maybe. Anyway, he collapses. He's in agony, his hands go to his eyes, he's immediately taken to the doctors, to the surgeons. From this point onwards, he can never again see
一个传奇在球场诞生。麦当劳的猛龙辣鸡肉肉汁奶酪薯条。我们世界著名的薯条上铺满了调味鸡肉、肉汁、浓郁的奶酪凝乳、玉米片，并淋上纳乔奶酪酱。
out of his right eye. His right eye has been hit with sand and all this rubbish and that's it, it's gone. So Dominic, to be honest, I think we've had quite enough drama as it is for this half, so let's take a break at this thrilling point. And when we come back, we'll see whether Nelson recovers from his eye injury, or whether he retires and no one ever hears of him again. A courtside legend is born. The Raptor Chicken Nacho Poutine from McDonald's. Our world famous fries topped with seasoned chicken, gravy, stringy cheese curds, tortilla strips, and drizzled with nacho cheese sauce.
抓住它。限时供应，仅在安大略省参与活动的麦当劳餐厅有售。你知道野心最棒的地方是什么吗？你看不到它。有些事情看起来很有野心，但外表可能是具有欺骗性的。例如，一个跑步者可能在为马拉松做准备，或者他们可能只是赶不上公交车。你永远不知道。
Get your claws on it. For a limited time only, I'm participating in McDonald's restaurants in Ontario. You know what's great about ambition? You can't see it. Some things look ambitious, but looks can be deceiving. For example, a runner could be training for a marathon, or they could be late for the bus. You never know.
野心在内心深处。所以那个公路旅行愿望清单？去实现它吧。驱动你的野心。三菱汽车。
Ambition is on the inside. So that road trip bucket list? Get after it. Drive your ambition. Mitsubishi Motors. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We left you on absolute tenterhooks, wondering whether the injury to his eye that Nelson sustained at the siege of Calvi will finish off his career, whether he will never be heard of again. Dominic, does it finish off his career or will we be hearing more of this promising young captain Horatio Nelson?
您好，欢迎收听《一切皆历史》。我们把您悬在绝对焦虑的悬念中，不知道纳尔逊在卡尔维围城战中受到的眼部伤亡是否会结束他的职业生涯，他是否会从此销声匿迹。多米尼克，这会结束他的职业生涯吗？还是我们会听到更多关于这位前途无量的年轻船长霍雷肖·纳尔逊的消息？
For Reed is keen to get stuck into Nelson here at the seas I'm very happy to say that this is not the end of his career What's amazing is that he doesn't even enter the injury in the ship's logs or even put himself on the official list of the wounded And he essentially tells it. I was just a scratch. Yeah, I mean, that's what he writes to Fanny, literally just a little scratch, but he's not telling her the truth. He's deliberately hiding the fact that he will never be able to see out of that eye again. And actually he never wears an eye patch or anything like that. And it's not that he'd lost his eye. His eye is there, but it looks just a little cloudy. Yeah. And he can only see out of his left eye. Calvi falls.
雷德渴望在这里深入探讨纳尔逊在海上的事迹。我非常高兴地宣布，这并不是他职业生涯的结束。令人惊奇的是，他甚至没有把这次受伤记录在船舰日志中，也没有把自己列入官方的受伤人员名单。他基本上告诉别人：“这只是个擦伤。”是的，我的意思是，这就是他写给范妮的信，字面意思只是一个小擦伤，但他没有告诉她真相。他刻意隐瞒了自己将再也无法用那只眼睛看见东西的事实。而且事实上他从未戴过眼罩之类的东西。并不是说他失去了眼睛。他的眼睛还在，只是看起来有点浑浊。是的。而且他只能用左眼视物。卡尔维陷落。
So Corsica is now in Britain's hands. And then there is a sort of a lull as is so often the case for naval wars. They're basically sent off to blockade and to faff around on the coast of Italy, blockading when the French, when they appear, stopping the French interfering. It's endless kind of blockade of leghorn out there. I mean, that's what it's all about. A lot of stuff in Lego in Livorno at this point. It seems pretty likely that Nelson, a lot of the sailors, of course, when they go on land, you know, in every port, exactly. They corrales in various ways. Should we say, and it seems very likely, I think there's an opera singer
所以科西嘉现在落入了英国手中。然后出现了一段间歇期，这在海军战争中往往是这样的。他们基本上被派去封锁并闲逛于意大利海岸，当法国人出现时进行封锁，阻止法国人干预。对里霍恩进行无休止的封锁。我的意思是，这就是全部内容。当时在利沃诺（里霍恩）有很多事情发生。看来很有可能纳尔逊、许多水兵，当然，当他们上岸时，你知道，在每个港口，确实如此。他们以各种方式寻欢作乐。我们不妨这么说，而且看起来非常明显，我认为有一位名叫阿德莱德·科雷利亚的女歌剧演员，纳尔逊与她有过一段轻浮的恋情或全面的关系。我想很明显他确实有过。因为他嫉妒另一个军官，不是吗？当这个其他军官在晚宴上坐在她旁边或诸如此类的时候。资料中有这段关系的蛛丝马迹。所以他随后只是闲逛了很长时间，什么也没发生。高层发生了人事变动。
called Adelaide Correglia that Nelson had either a flirtation or a full blown relationship with. I think pretty clearly he did. Because he's jealous of another officer, isn't he? When this other officer sits next to her at dinner or something like this. There are trace elements in the sources of a relationship. So he's then just faffing around for a long time, nothing happening. There's been a change at the top.
所以胡德海军上将，他的一个支持者走了，一个名叫威廉·霍瑟姆海军上将的人接任了，他有点老，也有点体弱多病……他人很好，对吧？他是个正派的人。他不是那种冲向敌人防线的人。不，他是那种“我们拥有什么，我们就守住什么，我们要小心，不要犯任何愚蠢的错误”的人，这根本不是纳尔逊的风格。他非常像我可能会成为的那种海军上将。哦，你知道，我们顺其自然吧。
So Admiral Hood, one of his patrons is gone and the guy called Admiral William Hotham comes in and he's just a bit old and a bit sickly and... He's nice, isn't he? He's a decent chap. He's not a man for charging at enemy lines. No, he's a kind of what we have, we hold, let's be careful, let's not make any silly mistakes and that's not Nelson at all. He's very much the kind of Admiral I would have been. Oh, you know, let's just take it.
轻松对待。是的。不，不是轻松对待，但我只是，你知道，我不想看好它。有点担心。你觉得我会是什么样的人，汤姆？嗯，我会告诉你我以为你会是谁，但我们会在下半场谈到这个。哦，迫不及待了。非常快。令人兴奋。所以有一个激动人心的时刻，因为他们听到热那亚海岸附近有法国船帆的报告。
Let's take it easy. Yeah. No, not take it easy, but I just don't, you know, I don't want to fancy it. A bit worried. What do you think I'd have been, Tom? Well, I'll tell you who I think you would be, but we'll come to him in the second half. Oh, I can't wait. Very imminently. Exciting. So there is an exciting moment because they hear reports of French sails off the
他们全都冲出去追踪他们并追上了他们。然后纳尔逊表现出了极大的勇气。关于这一点只需说两件事。首先是法兰西的船帆，我的意思是，它们拥有令人惊叹的革命名称系列。所以其中一艘叫做“圣赫拉”号。是的，革命之歌。没问题。是的，革命之歌。那是绝对的庞然大物，不是吗？它是世界上最大的双层甲板船。所以绝对是一艘巨大的船。但另一艘船叫做“松卡洛”号。所以纳尔逊毫无疑问他正面临着一支革命舰队。而且另一件要说的事是，纳尔逊到那时已经在海军服役了24年，他从未见过舰队在战斗中行动。这是他的
coast of Genoa. They all shoot out and they track them down and they catch up with them. And Nelson then shows tremendous courage. So just two things to say about this. The first is that the French sails, I mean, they have a tremendous array of revolutionary names. So one of them is called the Saint-Hera. Yeah, the revolutionary song. It will be fine. Yeah, the revolutionary song. And that's the kind of absolute monster, isn't it? It's the largest two-decker ship in the world. So absolutely enormous ship. But another ship is called the Song-Kalot. So Nelson can have no doubt that he is facing a revolutionary fleet. But also the other thing to say, Nelson has been in the Navy by this point for 24 years and he's never seen a fleet in action. This is his
第一次参战。我之前没想到这一点，但这是真的。是的。所以你可以想象他有多么激动。他等不及了。他投入其中。他说：“好，我们要直奔——你觉得他会直奔什么？”“圣赫拉”号，世界上最大双层甲板船。84门大炮，火力完全压倒了他自己的船“阿伽门农”号。你知道这对谁来说是个绝对的坏消息吗？法国人。这对法国人来说是个坏消息，但对于他在船上带的那七头阉牛来说，这也是个非常坏的消息。
first engagement in a battle. I hadn't thought about that, but it's true. Yeah. So you can imagine he is so excited. He can't wait. He gets stuck in. He says, right, we'll go straight for what do you think he goes for the satira, the largest two deck of ship in the world. 84 guns, completely outgunning his own ship, Agamemnon. And do you know who this is very bad news for? The French. It's bad news for the French, but it's also very bad news for the seven bullocks that he has on board.
这是他第一次参加海战。我以前没想过这一点，但确实如此。是的。所以你可以想象他有多么兴奋。他迫不及待了。他投入了战斗。他说，好，我们直接去攻击——你猜他选了什么？是“萨拉”号，世界上最大的一艘双层甲板战舰。拥有84门大炮，火力完全压倒了他自己的战舰“阿伽门农”号。你知道这对谁来说是个极其糟糕的消息吗？是法国人。这对法国人来说是个坏消息，但对于他船上载着的那七头阉牛来说，这也是个极其糟糕的消息。
Oh no, do they have to throw them overboard? Throw them overboard. Because when they beat to quarters and when they clear the decks for action, that often means that the livestock are just jettisoned. Just piled overboard. Yeah. Yeah. So he sails right up to the saira. Nelson thinks he will hold his
哦不，他们必须把这些牲畜扔过海吗？扔过海。因为当他们鸣鼓备战、清理甲板准备战斗时，往往意味着这些牲畜会被直接抛弃。直接扔进海里。是的。是的。于是他径直朝塞拉号驶去。纳尔逊认为他会按兵不动
fire until the last moment. Get in position so that every shot will count. And then he turns his ship and lets fly, firing again and again, pouring these broadsides into the sides of the saira. And because the saira is so large, the Agamemnon is much faster. It is deadly. It's like a kind of cobra striking at an elephant. Well, one of the sailors says that the saiyara could have swallowed up the Agamemnon. Yes. It doesn't matter.
直到最后一刻再开火。占领有利位置，确保每一炮都能命中。接着他调转船头，开炮还击，一次又一次地轰鸣，将一轮轮齐射倾泻在塞拉号的船舷上。由于塞拉号体积庞大，阿伽门农号的速度要快得多。这简直是致命的。就像眼镜蛇袭击大象一样。嗯，其中一个水兵说塞拉号本可以吞掉阿伽门农号。是的。这没关系。
I'll tell you what John Sugden wrote about this, about the broadside, that it was no amateur broadside, but a performance no other ship in the Mediterranean could have surpassed. I mean, that's the pinnacle of training that Nelson has brought his crew to. And it's lethal, isn't it? It's incredibly effective. The fighting goes on all day. The satyaraj is effectively crippled. They then have a kind of break to have a sleep and then they continue the next morning and it's like a test match. Yeah, it is. I mean, a lot of battles are like this though, aren't they? They take days. The satyaraj has got away and it's being towed or escorted by a smaller ship called the Sansur and Nelson catches up with them again. He
我告诉你约翰·萨格登关于这次齐射是怎么写的，这不是业余水平的齐射，而是地中海任何其他船只都无法超越的精彩表现。我的意思是，那是纳尔逊对其船员进行训练的巅峰。这简直是致命的，不是吗？极其有效。战斗持续了一整天。萨蒂亚拉号实际上已经残废了。接着他们休息了一会儿睡觉，第二天早上继续战斗，这就像是一场测试赛。是的，确实如此。不过我的意思是，很多战斗都是这样的，对吧？持续好几天。萨蒂亚拉号逃跑了，被一艘名为“桑苏尔”的小船拖带或护送，纳尔逊再次追上了他们。他
blasts them again. And the noise so deafening that in Genoa, people think that they can hear a storm coming from across the sea. And about 11 o'clock on the morning of the second day of the test, the two French ships strike their colors. That means they haul down their colors, they surrender. they haul down their colors, they surrender. And this to have captured two ships. Yeah, amazing. And especially one that's the largest. Yes, of its kind. To deck her in the world.
再次向他们猛烈开火。声音震耳欲聋，以至于在热那亚，人们以为他们听到海对岸传来了风暴。在大赛第二天的上午11点左右，这两艘法国军舰降下了他们的旗帜。这意味着他们收起旗帜，他们投降了。他们收起旗帜，他们投降了。就这样俘获了两艘船。是的，太惊人了。尤其是其中一艘还是最大的。是的，同类中最大的。世界上甲板最多的船。
Exactly. So the measure of Nelson's success is that he has lost three men, four of his men are wounded, but the French have lost over a hundred. And I think that it confirms Nelson's sense that attack is always the best policy because he now tested his assumption that British gunnery is better than French. And specifically, I think he feels that the Republican Navy has lost lots of its officers. It's lost lots of its self-confidence is pretty deficient in fighting spirit relative to his own men. And so that kind of absolutely confirms for him that faced with an enemy fleet, go for
没错。所以纳尔逊成功的衡量标准是，他损失了三名士兵，四名士兵受伤，而法国人损失了一百多人。我认为这印证了纳尔逊的信念，即进攻永远是最好的策略，因为他现在验证了自己的假设，即英国的炮火比法国的更精良。特别是，我觉得他感觉到共和党海军失去了很多军官。它失去了很多自信，与他自己的手下相比，它的战斗精神相当匮乏。因此，这对他来说绝对证实了一点，那就是面对敌方舰队，直接冲上去
it. That's exactly what he thinks. And he then says to Admiral Hotham, right, we've got these, let's go for the rest of the French fleet. And Hotham says, no, I don't think we will. And I quote, we must be contented. We've done very well. And Nelson is gutted by this because he felt this was an opportunity to go after the French fleet and to knock them out of this part of the Mediterranean. And Hotham, as far as he sees it, has been neglectful.
干就对了。他就是这么想的。然后他对霍瑟姆海军上将说，好啦，我们抓住这些了，让我们去进攻剩下的法国舰队吧。霍瑟姆说，不，我觉得我们还是算了吧。我引述他的话，“我们必须知足。我们已经做得非常好了。”纳尔逊对此感到痛心疾首，因为他觉得这是一个追击法国舰队并将其赶出地中海这一部分的绝佳机会。而在霍瑟姆看来，他一直疏于职守。
He has not taken the chance. But Nelson is the kind of commander who thinks that whenever you get the slightest glimmer of a chance, you must always, always go for it. So the Nelson touch, and that's what Hotham lacks. But fortunately Hotham gets replaced Christmas 1795 by a new commander. And this is the man who featured in the opening passage that I read at the head of this episode. And this is John Jervis. Yep. And John Sugden, great biographer of Nelson, has a tremendous description of Jervis.
他没有抓住这个机会。但纳尔逊是那种认为只要有一丝机会，就必须毫不犹豫地全力以赴的指挥官。所以这就是纳尔逊的风格，而这正是霍瑟姆所缺乏的。不过幸运的是，霍瑟姆在1795年圣诞节被一位新指挥官取代了。这就是我在本集开头阅读的那段引文中的主角。这就是约翰·杰维斯。没错。约翰·萨格登是纳尔逊伟大的传记作家，他对杰维斯有极好的描述。
His toad-like figure consisted of a stocky body, an expanding paunch propped up on thick tree trunk legs. But, I mean, in case you think that this is a man who's not qualified to command a fleet, I mean, he really is. He's called Old Oak. He's called old oak because basically he seems hewn out of English oak. And I think that if I'm a Hotham, you don't. That's kind. I love John Jervis. I wouldn't say I was toad-like, but I mean, I suppose I'll just have to suck it up. I think if you want to be compared to oak, you also have to suck that up.
他那如蟾蜍般的身材由结实的躯干组成，鼓起的腹部靠着树干般粗壮的双腿支撑着。但是，我的意思是，以防你认为这个人不具备指挥舰队的资格，实际上他完全具备。他被称为老橡树。他被称为老橡树，因为他基本上就像是用英国橡木雕刻出来的。我想如果我是霍瑟姆，你不会这么觉得。真客气。我喜欢约翰·杰维斯。我不会说我长得像蟾蜍，但我的意思是，我想我只能默默接受了。我想如果你想被比作橡树，你也必须接受这一点。
I mean, what I wrote about him myself was he had no patience for slackness and openly berated weaker men until they burst into tears. Yes. Is that how I behave? Yes. Oh, that's well. Can I do Chatham High Street? No. On the other hand, he could be kind to his men and love playing practical jokes on his junior officers. Well, Theo will vouch for that. Well, anyway, Jervis, I think he's a terrific commander. He's a bit of a martinet maybe. He is, but he's brilliant at spotting talent lower down. So, recognizing captains who have it and saying, yeah, I'm backing you. And obviously this is brilliant for Nelson, isn't it? So he comes in, he says, look, this is a Shambles. The ships are all dirty.
我的意思是，我自己对他的评价是，他对手下的懈怠毫无耐心，会公开斥责较弱的部下，直到他们放声大哭。是的。我是这样的人吗？是的。哦，好吧。我能在查塔姆高街这么干吗？不行。另一方面，他对手下也很友善，喜欢对低阶军官开恶作剧玩笑。韦奥可以为此作证。无论如何，杰维斯，我认为他是一位了不起的指挥官。他可能有点严苛。他是，但他在提拔下级人才方面非常出色。也就是说，认出那些有能力的船长并说，好的，我支持你。显然这对纳尔逊来说太棒了，不是吗？所以他一上任就说，听着，这简直是一团糟。船都很脏。
He orders soap. He says, wash the ships. There's too much drinking. There's girls on board. They've let the sanders slip. Nelson and the other younger captains love Jervis. They're like, brilliant. This is a guy who will take the war to the French.
他下令使用肥皂。他说，把船洗干净。喝酒的太多了。船上有女孩。他们让桑德斯溜走了。纳尔逊和其他年轻船长非常喜爱杰维斯。他们觉得太棒了。这是一个会把战争带给法国的人。
However, at this point, the French also have a new commander. And this is the man who we must encountered looking out over his thin, cruel smile. Yes, that is Napoleon Bonaparte. So Bonaparte has taken the war in Italy by storm. He has smashed the Austrians west of Genoa. He's got into Milan. He's crushed the army of the Pope. This is all in the spring of 1796 and he is rolling up the allied forces on land.
然而，就在此时，法国也迎来了一位新指挥官。这就是我们遇到的那位带着冷酷微笑的人。是的，那就是拿破仑·波拿巴。所以波拿巴以迅雷不及掩耳之势横扫了意大利的战局。他击溃了热那亚以西的奥地利军队。他进入了米兰。他粉碎了教皇的军队。这一切都发生在1796年春天，他正在陆地上瓦解盟军的势力。
And by doing that, he's rolling up the ports that the Royal Navy can visit. So Genoa closes its harbor to the Royal Navy that the Royal Navy can visit. So Genoa closes its harbour to the Royal Navy. The Royal Navy are forced out of Genoa. Then the Spanish should previously be on the other side, change sides and say, actually, we're going to back the French after all. Shocking behaviour from Spain, isn't it? Very bad behaviour from Spain. So Nelson has this, Nelson comments on what's going on.
通过这样做，他正在切断皇家海军可以访问的港口。因此热那亚对皇家海军关闭了港口，皇家海军可以访问。热那亚对皇家海军关闭了港口。皇家海军被迫撤出热那亚。然后之前站在对立面的西班牙改变了立场，表示事实上，他们最终还是决定支持法国。西班牙的行为太令人震惊了，对吧？西班牙的表现非常糟糕。所以纳尔逊对此发表了评论
We English have to regret that we cannot always decide the fate of empires on the sea. Yes. Well, I suppose that is the lesson, isn't it? It is the lesson. Absolutely. Commander of the sea can keep you safe, but it can't win you the war necessarily. Exactly. And then in the autumn of 1796, Jervis gets orders from London and these orders, he can't have been completely surprised, but he's clearly very disappointed. The orders are withdrawal from Corsica, shut down your operations in the Mediterranean, pull back
我们英国人不得不感到遗憾的是，我们无法总是在大海上决定帝国的命运。是的。好吧，我想这就是教训，对吧？这就是教训。绝对是的。掌握制海权可以保证你的安全，但未必能为你赢得战争。一点没错。然后，在1796年秋天，杰维斯收到了来自伦敦的命令，对于这些命令，他不可能完全不吃惊，但他显然非常失望。命令是撤出科西嘉岛，关闭你在地中海的行动，撤回
to Gibraltar. The Mediterranean is lost. You know, we have lost the Mediterranean campaign has all been. So it's a defeat. I mean, it's a palpable defeat. And Nelson is devastated by this. He writes to Fanny and he says, the tragedy of all this is we've actually never been fitter. We've never been better disciplined, we have a really good commander in Jervis but we are scuttling out of the Mediterranean with our tails between our legs and it's dishonourable he says to the dignity of England and he's not wrong, it is dishonourable to the dignity of England. Jervis gives him one last job, says there's a British garrison on the island of Elba,
直布罗陀。地中海失守了。你知道，我们输了，地中海战役完全失败了。所以这是一场失败。我的意思是，这是一场显而易见的失败。纳尔逊对此感到心碎。他写信给范妮说，这一切的悲剧在于我们实际上从未处于更好的状态。我们从未有过如此好的纪律，我们在杰维斯手下有一位非常优秀的指挥官，但我们却夹着尾巴灰溜溜地逃离地中海，他说这有失英国的尊严，他没说错，这确实有失英国的尊严。杰维斯给了他最后一份工作，说厄尔巴岛上有一个英国守备部队，
of course an island that will feature later in the, uh, in the story, in the story. He says, go off to Elba and get this garrison, which he does. On the way back, there's a skirmish with a couple of Spanish frigates. And it's during this skirmish that he first is really acquainted with a young Lieutenant, cause he's on a ship now called the Minerv because the agamemnon is being repaired. There's a Lieutenant on the Minerv called Thomas Masterman Hardy. And Hardy is a slightly sort of wooden figure himself, isn't he?
当然，这个岛屿后来会在故事中发挥重要作用。他说，去厄尔巴岛把这支守备部队接回来，他照做了。在回程的路上，与几艘西班牙护卫舰发生了一场小规模冲突。正是在这次冲突中，他真正结识了一位年轻的中尉，因为他当时在一艘名为密涅瓦号的船上，因为阿伽门农号正在修理。密涅瓦号上有一位名叫托马斯·马斯特曼·哈迪的中尉。哈迪本人也是个稍微有点木讷的人，对吧？
Yeah. Huge man, huge, slow, stooping. Like a kind of ox. Ox exactly. Yeah. But Hardy works incredibly hard. He's incredibly brave and he's very loyal to Nelson.
是的。身材魁梧，高大，行动迟缓，有些驼背。就像某种公牛。完全是公牛。是的。但哈迪工作极其刻苦。他极其勇敢，对纳尔逊非常忠诚。
Well, and also Hardy basically sacrifices himself. He gets captured by the Spanish to ensure that Nelson can get away with all his prizes and things like that. So Nelson owes him one. Then Hardy goes overboard and they go back and have a look for him. So Nelson has saved Hardy's life. So they are kind of bonded by that in a way that will keep them together right the way up to the very last minutes of Nelson's life. The mix of those two men, they become the huge man and the much smaller man. They become a sort of bit of mice and men also. They become quite a good kind of double act, don't they?
嗯，而且哈迪基本上牺牲了自己。他被西班牙人俘虏，以确保纳尔逊能够带着他所有的战利品顺利脱身。所以纳尔逊欠他一个人情。然后哈迪落水了，他们返回去找他。所以纳尔逊救了哈迪的命。因此他们以这种方式紧密联系在一起，这种联系将一直维持到纳尔逊生命的最后几分钟。这两个人的组合，他们变成了身材魁梧的人和身材娇小的人。他们也有点像人鼠之间。他们成了相当不错的一对黄金搭档，不是吗？
Well, it's asterisks and obelisks. Exactly. Yes, asterisks and obelisks is a good comparison. In the meantime, Nelson is now heading back towards Gibraltar and there he has been told rendezvous with Jervis's fleet off the southwestern coast of Portugal. But they've had news. The Spanish fleet has set sail. They think it is going to head west through the straits. It's going to head somewhere into the Atlantic and there it may well link up with the French
好吧，这就是星号与方尖碑的组合。没错。是的，星号与方尖碑是一个很好的比喻。与此同时，纳尔逊正朝着直布罗陀方向驶去，在那里他被告知要在葡萄牙西南海岸与杰维斯的舰队会合。但他们得到了消息。西班牙舰队已经起航。他们认为它将向西穿过海峡。它将驶向大西洋的某个地方，在那里它很可能会与法国
fleet off the coast of Brittany and form this great armada. And basically the British desperately want to intercept the Spanish fleet before this can happen. So as they're going through the Straits of Gibraltar, you know, it's very dark and foggy, incredibly thick fog. Nelson and his lookouts are kind of scouring the horizon for the Spanish. And overnight on the 11th of February, the lookouts on the Minerv say, we can hear voices in the fog. We can hear, we can see lights.
布列塔尼海岸附近的舰队会合，并组成这支庞大的无敌舰队。基本上，英国人迫切希望在发生这种情况之前拦截西班牙舰队。当他们穿过直布罗陀海峡时，你知道，天非常黑，有雾，浓雾弥漫。纳尔逊和他的瞭望员正在地平线上搜寻西班牙人。在2月11日的夜里，密涅瓦号上的瞭望员说，我们在雾中能听到声音。我们能听到，我们能看到灯光。
And it sounds a bit Spanish. And it sounds, yeah. And they realize they are literally sailing through the Spanish fleet. But in the fog, with their own lights dimmed and making no noise, they have not yet been detected. So on they go through the fog. Eventually the fog clears. Dawn comes. The lookout spot the masts of Jervis's fleet, which is waiting off Cape St Vincent and Nelson races to get to Jervis's fleet to tell him the news. Vincent and Nelson races to get to Jervis's fleet to tell him the news and Jervis is waiting impatiently aboard his flagship for news of the Spanish so that he can begin the attack.
听起来有点像西班牙语。听起来，是的。他们意识到他们实际上正穿过西班牙舰队。但在大雾中，他们的灯光调暗了，也没有发出声音，他们还没有被发现。于是他们继续在雾中前进。最终大雾散去。天亮了。瞭望员发现了杰维斯舰队的桅杆，该舰队正在圣文森特角外等待，纳尔逊飞奔去见杰维斯的舰队，把这个消息告诉他。文森特和纳尔逊飞奔去向杰维斯的舰队汇报这个消息，而杰维斯正急不可耐地在他的旗舰上等待着西班牙人的消息，以便他能够发动进攻。
And Dominic, what is the name of Jervis's flagship? It's named Tom. It's Victory. Well, absolute scenes. So the fleets are lining up off the Cape of St. Vincent and what will ensue the following day is one of the most extraordinary and heroic battles in the entire history of the Royal Navy and we will be coming to that in our next episode and if you simply can't wait and honestly I wouldn't be able to wait for it you can of course hear it straight away if you're a member of the Restless History Club and if
多米尼克，杰维斯的旗舰叫什么名字？它的名字叫汤姆。它是“胜利号”。哇，场面太壮观了。所以各舰队在圣文森特角外列队，随之而来的第二天将是皇家海军整个历史上最非凡、最英勇的战役之一，我们将在下一集中讨论这一点，如果你实在等不及了——老实说我也等不及了——如果你是“永动历史俱乐部”的会员，你当然可以立即收听，如果你
you're not you can go to therestlesshistory.com and sign up there. If not, it will be out very soon in due course. So we will see you very soon on the high seas to meet with the Spanish fleet. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不是会员，你可以访问 therestlesshistory.com 在那里注册。如果不是的话，它很快就会适时推出。所以我们很快就会在公海上见面，去会合西班牙舰队。再见。本集暂时还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。